In a city of unusual sights.
This one sticks out.
Check out what was spotted
over the skies of Las
Vegas a few weeks ago.
All right.
Check it out right there.
You could see that green light
kind of streaking down toward earth.
And it's moving pretty fast there.
Just a short time
after that light is seen,
police responded to a 911
call about a, quote, non-human visitor
in a local backyard.
Would you say
it was like a it was like a big creature?
A big creature? Yeah. Like a real person.
I'm not going to be sick, guys.
One of my partners
said they saw some fall in the sky, too.
So that's why I'm kind of curious.
Did you see anything on land
in your backyard
or they see like a big
city, like a big like a big were like,
oh, I don't know. I'm so nervous.
Right now. I have butterflies, bro.
I was shooting star then.
These people say there's
aliens in the backyard.
Uh huh.
Okay, well,
officers did investigate, but.
But found
no sign of that creature, that ten foot
tall creature.
Later, the officer joked to the family,
if the creatures come back,
they need to call someone else for help.
All right.
To discuss, we're joined by Adam Frank.
He's a professor
of astrophysics
at the University of Rochester
and author of Light of the Stars
Alien Worlds
and the Fate of the Earth,
and also the upcoming
The Little Book of Aliens.
Those folks in Las Vegas
probably wish
they had that little book of aliens.
Professor okay, so what do you think?
I mean, that video,
the Green Streak, that's unusual,
but that very ominous
description of creatures.
What do you think is going on here?
Well, you know, when I was a kid,
my parents used to tell me
when we went camping, they tell me
ghost stories. Right.
And it would make the hairs
on the back of my neck raise up.
And that's basically what this is, right?
Because that that that light
you see in the sky,
it's a meteor
and it stays exactly the way
I would expect the meteor to fade.
And so, you know, for whatever reasons,
I don't know if it was a big dog.
I just don't know.
The ten foot tall dog, ten foot,
really? Ten feet tall. Wow.
So these
what's important about this
kind of thing is
that this is like
the whole history of UFOs. Right.
I mean, right in one story, right?
Somebody sees something,
and then you get a story, and.
But there's never anything to do,
you know,
there's never any real evidence.
There's never anything that last
there's never anything that science
which allows us to have this
amazing conversation over
these wires can do anything with.
And so it's like, right here
is the entire history of UFO.
It's like the skeptics
will say one thing,
the believers will say the other thing.
But you're not left
with anything
to answer this incredible question of
is there life in the universe?
Interest thing?
Okay.
Well, back to your premise of your book,
The Little Book of Aliens.
So you do believe there's
something out there?
There can be something out there,
right, for you to have a book like that.
So you know, for people to see.
Well, now you're saying it's
probably a meteor.
You know, I don't know.
What do you what do you say to people,
especially the people in that backyard
who are pretty certain
they saw something?
I mean, what's the best explanation
as to
why their eyes
were playing tricks on them?
Well, for something
like this, there's
nothing I can say to them, right?
I wasn't there.
They don't
they can't give me any hard evidence.
They can't give me anything
that science can work with.
You know,
the main
premise of my book
is trying to tell people
the extraordinary progress science
is making
in finding life in the universe,
but not here on Earth.
On distant planets
like the James Webb Space Telescope
can see into the atmospheres of worlds
that are ten light years away. Right.
That's
how we're going to answer this question,
because I there's nothing I can do.
When someone tells me a story,
it's not like I'm going to tell them
they're lying. I don't know.
I wasn't there.
But the question
is this amazing method
we have called science,
which a lot gives us
cell phones and airplanes,
and we turn to every time
there's a crisis.
This method
is a way of talking to the world
that can give us answers back.
It's a way to be in dialog
with the world.
And if we want to know
about life in the universe,
that's the only way
we can answer the question.
So if it happens again,
whether it be those,
you know, folks in Las Vegas
who see something
green don't
necessarily their instinct doesn't say
it's a meteor.
I mean, who are you going to call?
Who should they call them?
Call the police.
They call the dog power, calls
you very large,
called the very large dog pound.
I mean, I don't know.
I don't know.
But it's not
you know, you take pictures,
but always what you see is right.
It's always fuzzy blobs.
We've got people
talking about UFOs for 50 years
and it's always fuzzy blobs.
Look at the picture that the
that pilot took up the Chinese
spy balloon. Right.
It's a selfie with him holding it up.
And you can see exquisite detail.
You can see the balloon.
You can see the
the had the cargo package underneath it
with unicorns.
It's always a fuzzy blob, you know.
Well, Adam,
I always loved talking to you.
I was really looking forward to this.
But I'm I've got to admit,
I'm kind of bummed.
I thought you were going
to give us something, you know,
I don't know, a little bit
more interesting
to allow us to all believe
and think that, yeah,
there is a ten foot creature out
there that comes with these
but what I can tell you is science.
Science is boring,
but it has to be boring.
It's long
and it's slow,
but it's the only way
that you get to know
truly amazing things.
And the amazing things are right
outside your door.
They're the ant colony.
They're the leaves.
But science is away, and it just have to,
you know, listen to the process.
Follow the process.
All right.
Wonders will be help.
Keep it interesting.
Adam, Frank, great to see you.
Thanks so much.